[Applause]
I
[Music]
[Applause]
today is where we finally want
the government to hear that
hospital workers and people who
work in all
social action centers are upgraded
that salaries are up to par  that the
staff stop leaving since
now the staff is leaving because
of the wages of the working conditions
so the empty coc he has a good back but it's
bad today's kobe that makes the
staff exhausted the enthusiasts
broadcast for years the
health crisis has accentuated to federate the
situation precisely in terms of
professionals and staff the
professions are unattractive are
painful and we have a lot of
professionals who are now leaving the
establishments it is time for this
government to start in any case
fana rial measures that can respond to
their request and we want to shout our
anger over the suffering we
have in iao hospitals  covit of
course but also linked to the politics
that we have been subjected to for about 15 years
here we have had a salary freeze since
since 2010 you have to know
[Music]